all right friends before we get started
talking about the mando season 2 finale
i want to thank the sponsor of this
video this video is brought to you by
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with
thousands of classes covering a wide
variety of creative skills
illustration graphic design film and
video general creative expansion that's
just to name a few as well as classics
like creative writing
creative writing to me is a very
important thing the pen truly is
mightier than the sword have you ever
just
had a story in your head and you didn't
know how to get it out there
creative writing my friends there's a
solid first step for you and wherever
your creativity takes you in your
skillshare adventures
it's less than ten dollars a month with
an annual membership and the first 1000
of my subscribers to click the link
below will get a free premium trial
membership so click the link below get
started on that creative path and thank
you once again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right
[Music]
spoilers this is the thing where it's
like when i say
spoiler alert don't watch unless you've
seen it i know there's
a percentage of people who are like yeah
but
how spoilers could it be and do i care
about the spoilers well if you're a star
wars-y person yes i'm basically telling
family like my brother i know that he
wants to binge
mando when it's all out it's all out now
but also he's my brother
so he likes supporting me and watching
my videos if you're watching this dude
turn it off now you know watch mando and
then come back anyhow spoiler alert done
and as this is the finale there are
things to talk about but really there's
one thing that people want me to talk
about maybe i'm projecting because it's
the thing i want to talk about but there
are things
leading up to it in which i'm going to
talk about those first so it starts out
and they get bo katan's help which i'm
glad they get bo katan's help because
before i was like she really missed the
boat on
sticking around mando and getting
straight to mob gideon so i'm glad
amanda was like hey you wanna
let's go get him off get in now you want
to but then she looks at boba fett and
she's like you're not a man delorean i
was like
i man hold on so the scenario is
boba fett was a mandalorian and then
they wreck on that and made him not a
mandalorian and then they retconned the
retcon in the mandalorian and made boba
fett a mandalorian and then bo katan the
would-be
leader of the mandalorians who i think
has a pretty good handle
on who is and is not a mandalorian tells
boba fett no
you're not a mandalorian do not take a
shot every time i say mandalorian
i don't want you to die but man i just
kind of
i was i don't know if confused or
frustrated i just
i i think back to a time when you could
know what was going on in star wars
and you didn't need a doctorate in the
degree titled
galaxy for far away ology the point is
they concoct this plan
get into the imperial cruiser because
mando's like
i want to get grogu back and that is the
plan and there are dark troopers at
first i was like oh dark troopers this
is going to be metal
then one gets through the door and
mando's fighting the dark trooper
which is i mean they're pretty dumb
though i mean it was cool that he was
punching mando's head and his helmet
wasn't taking any damage because it's
it's super strong but they were denting
the wall with his helmet i just found it
funny that this dark trooper is supposed
to be this super
dangerous next level droid and he's like
i can't get through his helmet i don't
know just
i guess the more i try but any machine
worth its salt
be like can't get through the armor but
you know what he still has limbs
that's right mando now you have a broken
leg now you're [ __ ] which makes it
even funnier that that scientist dudes
like oh we solved the human elements
and now these aren't suits they're not
troopers they're dark troopers they're
droids we've taken the human element out
we've perfected the soldier but any
human soldier would have adapted to that
situation and
broken a limb federation makes droids
jedi beat droids
republic makes troops troops defeat jedi
empire makes droids so mando beats dark
troopers ass the rest get blown out of
an airlock so
that was that internet chatter about
dark troopers it felt kind of bad for
people who were like dark troopers
they're finally canon
yeah they come back they come back to
die again
we're getting there soon my friend soon
we'll talk about it but mando shows up
to grow gusel in which moff gideon has
the dark saber two baby grogu mando's
like i don't even care
you can keep the dark saber i just want
the kid i just want grow goo back moff
gideon's like
i can feel it the connection it hits me
where i live
take him but you know this isn't our
first bioware game
we've all been there right on some
assassin mission or something the
person's like wait let me just do this
thing
just give me a second i'm totally not
going to draw a weapon on you or try to
kill you or alert the guards so you know
moff giddy and being the villain starts
swinging the dark saber at mando they
get into a fight which that is a hot toy
spoiler right there because hot toys
release hey this is our moff gideon
figure which hot toys is usually
pretty accurate to what happens on
screen and there's a dark saber blade
that is moff gideon
swinging the darksaber and i was like he
has not swung the darksaber in the
series yet which means in the finale
he's going to get into a fight with the
darksaber you've got to know you got to
know your product you got to watch out
for that [ __ ] and the dark troopers come
back they
they were in space and they're like dude
we have rockets
it's fine and it's looking pretty dire
they're about to bust through the door
and then one x-wing fighter shows up and
i was like okay so the new republic is
it's gonna be one x-wing fighter they'll
be like just one and then a bunch
are gonna show up a whole fleet is gonna
be fine but no it's just one x-wing
fighter and it took me
there was a trickle of realization after
that i was like one x-wing fighter
no then jedi road person plops down i
was like nope
you know because i can't fully i can't
give myself over to that kind of hope
these days
i just can't i don't know if it's 20 20
or just my age in general i do not trust
or hope
it has forsaken these lands but you
start recognizing those boots really
quickly and when i saw
the black glove only on one hand
only on his right hand the other hand
had no glove i was like
oh my god it's luke skywalker i was i
said out loud i was like
that's [ __ ] luke skywalker they
weren't showing his face at first i
didn't care the whole episode i was like
you don't even have to show his face the
fact that it's luke that's enough for me
because
we're getting what we wanted like fans
wanted this
ever since what was it 2012 2013 we
learned star wars movies were coming
back
there was gonna be an episode seven time
flies but you know you have that hope
for that scenario where
everyone's it's this dire situation
people need hope they need a hero
and luke comes in to save the day people
thought that was gonna happen in the
last jedi
and it didn't and all they wanted was
this this is all i wanted because it
is as simple as this people love their
heroes and they love their heroes
acting heroic and luke straight up as a
hero and he heroically
tears these dark troopers down he makes
these droids
look like the battle droids and phantom
menace just shradden them and now we've
come full circle to jedi
beats droids i will say when luke grabs
that one dark trooper with the force and
crushes him i was like
that is the son of anakin skywalker all
right that's a very anakin skywalker
move right there
i liked it i just liked the fact that
that connection was there and yeah he
gets to the bridge and i was like is a
sebastian stand up no they're doing that
deep fake cgi but not deep fake so it's
a cgi face that they did for grand moff
tarkin
and leia and rogue one which yeah you
could totally tell it's a cgi face
i can't i wish they'd recast that
uncanny valley you know it's like a real
human just
feels more human this you appreciate the
scene but you can't help but be like
and the cgi phase it's funny lucasfilm
disney they're weird you know like
on one hand they're like we can't recast
people on the other hand they're like
well sometimes we can maybe it's like if
they want to bring him back
for more things all right then they'll
recast him which will make the cgi
face stand out more because it's like
yeah cgi face luke
then shortly afterwards real face luke
the fact that he has one glove and
uh one hand without a glove one could
call him
cool hand luke i'm done but i don't know
why i thought of that
i just did but there was a part of me
that was like is he gonna say i'm luke
skywalker i'm here to rescue you because
then you know
chain of thought starts happening it's
like well then bo katana be like you're
luke who now
but he didn't say that which i'm glad he
didn't say that that was just one of
those
weird subconscious fan moments like is
he gonna but that would have been
that would have been cheesy so i'm glad
he didn't do that he just pops in and
he's like
i'm here for him which can we just kind
of take a chuckle at the fact that bo
katan was in the room with the son of
anakin skywalker and just didn't know it
but then after this
this moment of oh my god luke is back
and he's doing exactly
what we all wanted him to do it's not
jake it's not his grumpy uncle jake
it's luke then we're met with this
emotional moment where
mando has to give grogu to luke
skywalker and
grogu doesn't really want to go and
grogu wants his permission
and you know he touches his helmet i'm
like yeah [ __ ] he wants to see his face
and he takes off the helmet for him it's
it's this really good moment man like
the whole thing with mando that i like
is that you feel like when we first saw
him he was on the path to basically
being
the other boba fett you know the next
boba fett but then there's this moment
where he
the package is this kid and he just
makes a call and he's like
nah i suppose there's another reality
out there for mando yeah this fictional
character
so there's not i guess but you know but
for him
and his character there is where he was
like yeah i'll give the kid over i'm a
bounty hunter and he doesn't find this
human connection he didn't know he
needed but you know he did
it's it's just a fundamental story of
connection and growth i dig it which
means when he has to say goodbye it's
just
it's sad you know it's a touching thing
and it gives him to luke skywalker you
know take care of him looks like
i will ah [ __ ] well i tried is that the
implication
is the implication grogu dies
or are we just wiping all that from
cannon because disney has already
wiped away cannon once before we had all
those books you know those timothy zahn
books air to the empire and all that and
disney was like that's no longer canon
now these are canons so they could just
be like
yeah episode 789 they're no longer canon
because we can do that because we've
done it before
who knows where they're going but i'll
tell you this mandalorian season two
ward on its sleeve man delorean appeared
to be a couple things
it's exactly the couple things that
mandalorian season two showed
it actually is which is a fun star wars
show to scratch that star wars itch
that's the easy one
but also a hub to springboard other
spin-off series for other characters
that is also happening whether it's
ahsoka boba fett bob with a hut as he's
apparently called now
post credit scene it's in here boba fett
goes back to jabba's old palace where
bib
fortuna is uh he has become a hut for
tuna tune to the hut
so boba fett kills him and becomes boba
the hutt which is good i think that's
good for boba fett i think that's
a place that i could see him ending up
but that's my point star wars show to
scratch that star wars itch
hub to springboard other spin-off shows
but also that thing that was
they had their work cut out for him on
this one but bringing luke in
was definitely that right direction for
it the mandalorians that thing
to get fans back on the side of star
wars giving people this
smart call and also pretty [ __ ] sweet
to see i do have questions though there
are things that leave up that are
unresolved which you know it's good to
do it's good
good to have something lead into the
next season but mando has a dark saber
he earned the dark saber i guess because
the darksaber's kind of like wands and
harry potter i suppose
as someone who does not have a doctorate
in
the degree of galaxy far far away ology
felt like i did
for a large section of my life and then
the lord just exponentially
tenfold grew and now i'm just like you
know what i'm pretty solid on the first
six movies though
there's that sorry the scenario as i
took it was mando beat moff gideon he
has the darksaber but he earned the
darksaber because he beat him
in their fight so it's like you can't
just give the dark saber to bo katan
she has to beat you in a fight so
amanda's like i don't want it i yield
here it's like no it doesn't work that
way
you know people will know you yielded
and she won't be seen as a leader
so you have to fight her the implication
being either mando or bo katan's going
to die in this
duel but mando got the dark saber by
beating him off giddy and a maf gideon
didn't die
so i suppose bo katan just has to beat
him in a fight it's like all right well
we can just plan this out make it like a
wwe event you know it's like
we'll make it look good for the fans but
in the end the scripts
we know where the script is going to
take the winner at first i was like whoa
that's a
really sticky situation they're in one
of them has to die but it doesn't look
like one of them actually has to do with
moff giddy and didn't so yeah
mandalorian season two
in the end i dug it it's one of those
shows i still think you
need to watch from beginning to end like
the week to week's fine but i want to
sit down and
now watch it from beginning to end keep
saying and like the show's over
the show's going on i mean without the
mando baby grogu dynamic
i don't know but the beginning was
episodic there was some flow and ebb but
really epic episodes that i really dug
most of which tied into pre-existing
star wars
characters that i like but this was
exactly how you want to finish off the
season 2 finale by giving people what
they wanted
in 2015. all right so the mandalorian
season 2 finale have you seen it i hope
you have if you saw this video
but what did you think about it what'd
you think of the finale what'd you think
of the season as a whole whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you